make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and a lot of you guys know i'm
not really huge on rumors however there
is one that caught my attention which
has basically established that
shumogorath is going to appear in doctor
strange too so in this video i'm going
to make you guys an expert on
shumogorath now here's the thing
shumogorath is very very very very
powerful
but there are different iterations of
shumogorath which is to say when he
sends like a copy of himself versus the
actual shumogorath himself so this goes
back pretty far well not really
far but actually a pretty obscure comic
which was released in 2014 called marvel
fact files and in issue number 46 they
actually detailed the story
of schumacher at least to a degree what
this really revealed is that shumo
garath was
also or really was a mini angled one now
up to this point we didn't really know
that for certain
we largely believed it but for those of
you guys who don't know what the meaning
angled ones are and the reason why this
is so important for doctor strange too
in marvel comics the way the multiverse
works is wide and varying right there's
a lot of moving parts you have the omni
russell development court you've got the
time variance authority
you've got different teams like the
exiles oh you've got the multiversal
avengers which were written by uh well
really they started in hickman's run and
then continued on in al ewing's ultimate
avengers run
you've got uh the custodian of the
multiverse you've got the multiversal
eternity you got a lot of stuff going on
there but what you have here
are different universes and so if you
imagined this giant empty space
and each universe was like a circle or
like a world unto itself
then the space between those universes
is what the mini angled ones inhabit
they basically occupy that space so i
always liken it to a brick wall in the
sense that the universes or bricks and
the mini angled ones
are in the spaces or the mortar between
the bricks that's usually how i always
kind of kind of label that but they're
basically super powerful beings
chumagorath is largely considered to be
the most powerful out of all of them now
in more recent years marvel has
introduced this interesting concept
called kogoth which is basically like
this servant that was created by
schumacher
and that was covered in wolverine first
class issue number 12 which was actually
not too long ago you can include that if
you want to
it's not super important the important
thing about shumo gorath is that in the
early days of earth he along with the
rest of the great old ones which are
sometimes referred to as the elder gods
although that's kind of a
of a misnomer had basically ruled the
world one of the funny things about the
many angled ones though is that by and
large they actually
predate the universe and that's why
there's no real definitive origin as to
where the great old ones or the meaning
angled ones or whatever you want to call
them where they actually come from the
elder gods do have a definitive origin
we've covered that before but for the
many angled ones they really don't right
some of them kind of predate the
universe some of them are considered to
be demonic in nature so they come from
demonic dimensions
we don't really know exactly where they
hail from what we do know is that at
some point shumogorath made his way to
earth
and then basically started ruling it in
a pretty horrible way
right literally feasting on people
absorbing their energy different things
along those lines but around a million
years before the modern era what you got
was a guy named seismic now seize nag
was a really cool character he was
stupidly powerful by the end of his
attempt to
garner all magical energy across the
universe into himself he basically
became god but he came from the 31st
century and at that point in time
most of humanity had learned how to use
magical energy but magical energy was
finite and so there were constant
conflicts and battles
over who would be able to wield the most
amount of energy people trying to take
the ability from other people
so on and so forth killing people off so
there would be less competition and so
on but seize nag actually sought to go
back to the source of magical energy and
then absorb it there and then make
himself a god now one of the reasons why
seize nag is such an interesting
character
specifically with regards to the marvel
cinematic universe is that in the mcu in
doctor strange you had a book called the
book of cagliostro you guys probably
remember that when the ancient one was
talking about it the reason why that
matters is because
in marvel comics there was a point
during his time-hopping
capers and so on when seismic showed up
in
relatively the modern era and then
created the identity of cagliostro and
then wrote down
all his knowledge of magical energy in
that book and that's why a lot of marvel
comics fans
are exceedingly excited about the the
book of kagliostro in the mcu because it
means we could see seismic because the
book itself does not have an origin
in the mcu we don't know exactly where
it came from and so because of that
ultimately one of the things that
happens and you had a couple things take
place
in terms of the main form of of schuma
gorath this was defeated about 20 000
years before the modern day and this
actually takes place in the old conan
stories which is interesting enough
because conan dealt with a lot of
monsters demons different things like
that
and so what you got was that in conan
the barbarian issue number 260 in 1992
by roy thomas you got this story where
following the defeat of shumo gorath at
the hands of seisenegg that he basically
found a way to return and when he did he
started ruling about 20 000 years before
the modern era
and did so in much the same way that he
did before he'd been defeated ultimately
people basically sent out a call for
help to the conan god krom
who basically created these three books
and when a shaman went to go confront uh
schumacher
mcgrath was ultimately defeated and then
locked inside these things which were
called the ironbound books of shumagora
and the way this worked is that these
books if they were used
and and essentially if they were
manipulated a person
could actually free shumagorath so for
those of you guys coming from like one
division it's very similar to the dark
hole in the sense that uh the the demon
god cathone
is always trying to use the darkhold as
a means to return to the main universe
and conquer it
uh shumogorath is always trying to get
individuals to use the ironbound books
to basically release him into the modern
era but
this tale of schuma gorath is actually
expanded on
in the again the old conan stories and
actually a little bit of a build up to
conan 260 which actually started in 252
and then ran through 254 255 and then
257
into 260. and the way this played out is
it basically told us
that following his defeat by the shaman
with shumo gorath continuing this
campaign to get people to use the iron
books
this basically led to a couple different
characters one was a guy by the name of
cool and gath
and the second was the hiborian demon
which queen by the name of
vamitar now this essentially led to
these various armies or really these
these two individuals their armies
fighting to a standstill and then what
ended up happening
is that the ironbound books of
shumogorath were ultimately used and
that while vamitar had the books
themselves
that uh coulon gath actually had the key
to open the books and so the way this
played out is that krom and intervened
and actually sent an avalanche which
basically buried the books so that
nobody could really really use them and
ultimately uh both of these different
sorcerers kind of went their separate
ways believing that each one had been
dead
eventually when you got into conan the
barbarian issue number 252
you end up learning that conan along
with a companion by the name of hob had
basically traveled north in order to
confront the enchantress of amitar and
then ultimately hob was basically taken
by shumagorath and forced to read the
ironbound books which in doing so
freed shumogorath from his prison now
the story itself would ultimately
conclude with shumogorath being
re-imprisoned by by krom
and essentially locked away again and he
would really remain there for quite some
time
until you get to the old doctor strange
stories now the idea of schuma gorath
appearing in the doctor strange stories
are really a hallmark of the character
and this came in marvel premiere in
issues number three through ten
and this basically saw doctor strange
and the ancient one facing off against
basically
most all of their major enemies outside
of dormammu and then ultimately doctor
strange realizes that they're all kind
of being manipulated and used
and being sent forward as more or less
pawns when he traces this back to its
source
he discovers that shumogorath is
basically doing this as a means to try
to find a way to escape
and that shumagorath is destined to
escape by using the mind of the ancient
one and so this basically led to the
original comic book version
of how the ancient one died and so what
this saw was that doctor strange
ultimately had to kill the ancient one
in order to stop shumogorath from
re-emerging one of the things that i do
want to point out here is that in the
doctor strange mythos
this is huge this is probably one of the
most significant moments in the story uh
really in the history of his character
for a couple different reasons the first
is because of the fact that this was
part of the hero's journey right so the
mentor ultimately dying and the hero
having to go forward of their own accord
with the skills they've learned and
and do various things but two it showed
the power of shumagora
that in doctor strange comics at that
point in time and even in marvel comics
as a whole
doctor strange was almost nigh
omnipotent right this guy could do
virtually anything he wanted to if the
story required him to do it and marvel
would just chalk it up to some use of
spells
the ancient one was more powerful than
steven strange was and so the fact that
stephen strange had to kill
his mentor in order to stop schuma
gorath from coming through
blew the minds of people at the time i
only know by virtue of having read the
letters pages but you guys should go
back and read them if you ever get a
chance
in the old marvel premiere stories
especially in number 10 it's kind of
nuts now in strange tales issues 9
through 14
this would really expand on the
schumacher mythos in a few different
ways
one of the first ways this did this was
by way of steven strange having to face
off against schuma gorath directly now
this also
invoked something called the wings of
needless sorrow which are pretty cool
they're an interesting concept you don't
really see them all too often but it's
basically a source of magic used by
steven strange
in light of using what's essentially
light side magic or good magic now the
reality is that when it comes to magic
and marvel comics dark side magic
is pretty interesting doctor strange for
the most part tries to shy away from it
agatha harkness in marvel comics has
said on multiple occasions that black
magic
and white magic or light magic or
whatever they're all basically the same
thing and you just use them for
different ends
uh but at the end of the day dark magic
is one of those things where when you
use it
it has a tendency to to influence your
soul right and to screw you up
uh to basically turn you into a dark and
twisted version of yourself
now initially doctor strange was not
really big on using it but then he came
in contact with a guy by the name of
kalu
or or kaluyu it depends on how you want
to pronounce it i always call him kalu
he was basically at one point the friend
of the ancient one and then turned enemy
uh ultimately he's the one that
essentially told steven strange the only
way to really defeat the old ones or the
mini angled ones
especially somebody like schuma gorath
is to use dark magic and so at the time
because of previous actions steven
strange was not really able to use the
eye of agamotto and so ultimately had to
revert to using the wings of needless
sorrow and all this really does at least
as far as it's been told from
from how it was told in this story um as
well as future appearances especially
during infinity
is that the wings of needless sorrow
allow the user to essentially absorb
magical energy from virtually anybody
around them and that's exactly what
steven strange did that he actually
absorbed magical energy from all
kinds of people including an uh
including one of the chaos lords aryak
and so this basically led to him
traveling directly to the realm to the
home realm
of shumogorath and this is when you saw
a lot of expansion because one of the
things that we learned in this story is
that shumogorath had actually conquered
multiple dimensions there were different
universes out there all of which had
been conquered
by uh by shumogorath and all the people
in those individual universes
basically worshiped him like a god and
so in essence the the modern day version
of earth would have simply just been
another world that was conquered by
schuma gorham that really that's really
all it would have been
uh but ultimately stephen strange is
successful in defeating shumakora but
also at the cost of himself
in particular and the reason why is
because stephen strange was basically
warned by shumo gorath due to the power
he possesses and because of the fact
that stephen strange was siphoning off
the power of shumogorath as the two of
them fought that if stephen absorbed
that through the wings of needless
sorrow that he would ultimately become
shumagorath and that's basically what
happened and so ultimately when
shumogorath was kind of defeated
and then confined back to a different
dimension that stephen strange had to go
on a kind of spirit journey of sorts to
basically remove the influence of
shumogorath from his own body and then
returned back to his normal self
but following that shumogorov had a few
appearances here and there he had some
appearances involving nicholas scratch
in uh in the fantastic four stories
really with uh issue number 26
which was written by roberto aguero
sakasa i'm pretty sure i'm messing that
name up
but over over time schumacherth was one
of these characters that largely just
kind of fell
into a bit of obscurity in the sense
that he was one of the early doctor
strange villains he had some cool
stories about him but all that really
changed by the time you got into the
more modern era now this particularly
dealt with the launch of what was called
the second iteration of the mighty
avengers and the way this played out is
that you had the the main mighty
avengers team for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with that the mighty
avengers were originally formed as
a carol danvers captain marvel team or
really miss marvel as she was known at
the time which was kind of a compliment
to the existing avengers roster
which was pro-superhuman registration
following the events of civil war
and so the mighty avengers basically
served as like the long arm of the law
and they would travel around and round
up superheroes who didn't
who hadn't registered like they were
supposed to now by the time the second
iteration of the mighty avengers came
around that was already gone but the
team had been
formed by uh by luke cage and then it
had a roster of like spectra monica
rambo
you had blue marvel you had a lot of
different characters who were there what
ended up happening during this event was
actually part of the larger infinity
story and that's when you basically saw
thanos showing up on earth
and so in a lot of ways part of the plot
of what you saw in infinity war and
avengers end game but the ebony maw had
basically traveled to stephen strange
and despite not really having any powers
into himself
actually talked steven strange into
using the uh really bringing back the
wings of needless sorrow and then
in turn re-bringing back uh shumagura
now
the version of shumogorath that returned
during infinity was only a copy of
himself it was not actually shumogorath
but it was enough to cause a massive
amount of panic now ultimately it was
destroyed by blue marvel which basically
saw adam beshear
just flying through the head of
shumogoras and completely destroying him
now i would say the last significant
moment of shumogorath really came
by way of doctor strange damnation which
is a story that we haven't necessarily
covered yet um and we can if you guys
are
are really interested and we might once
we get closer to doctor strange too
because we are quite some time out
before that movie releases but basically
this
saw a handful of things happening but
one of the biggest things that took
place is i saw mephisto taking up
residence in las vegas now for those of
you guys who are not familiar with
mephisto he's basically one of the many
iterations of satan in marvel comics but
the closest to satan that you have
in marvel satan himself as he's
traditionally depicted in
judeo-christianity doesn't
necessarily exist you do have like damon
hellstrom right like the son of satan
uh but it does get a little murky when
it comes to the various hell lords the
closest thing we have now in marvel
comics is the one below alt right kind
of the antithesis to the one
above all and the source of like all
evil that exists throughout the entirety
of creation
not enough has been revealed about the
one below all to truly understand the
purpose that it serves
it's somebody just there and honestly we
don't really know if we will see a lot
because i think we have like
three issues before al ewing basically
finishes his run
on the immortal hulk but during the
damnation story what you really saw here
was kind of like a massive war that took
place
between the different uh hell lords that
all existed inside the
the demonic dimensions and mephisto
ultimately emerged victorious
and then locked away pretty much all the
various hell lords and their different
iterations in a kind of secret realm
schuma gorath was one of the people who
was locked away ultimately he was met by
the arrival of the ultimate avengers and
doctor strange and then dormammu
intervened indoor mammo actually ended
up in a fight with shumo gorath which
was pretty cool um and then essentially
shumagorath was more or less kind of
defeated and then confined back to his
dimension again but that's largely the
role the characters played right the
most significant moments regarding
schuma gore at the marvel comics have
long since gone right because doctor
strange even among himself
is kind of more of a background
character than marvel comics i mean he
kind of has a solo series but you don't
really see him doing
anything near as much as he used to in
like the early 90s and any period before
that right like
uh he's just largely been a background
character it's just kind of the nature
of things some of the more recent
stories have been cool but again shumo
gorath just as an extension of being
largely a doctor strange villain has
fallen into even more obscurity
uh than dr strange kind of had just
because of the fact that there's just
other things that i guess marvel wants
to focus on i don't really have an
answer to the question of why marvel
doesn't do much with schuma gorath
anymore with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you